hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 38 hört zu und
spricht nach
wie gefällt dir das lied wie gefällt dir
das lied es gefällt mir sehr gut
es gefällt mir sehr gut
wie gefällt dir der film wie gefällt dir
der film er gefällt mir nicht so gut
er gefällt mir nicht so gut
welche musik hörst du gern welche musik
hörst du gern welchen musik stil magst
du welchen musik stil magst du
[Musik]
ich höre gern technik
ich höre gern technik die melodie von
diesem lied gefällt mir die melodie von
diesem lied gefällt mir
mir gefällt der rhythmus von dem lied
ich finde den text von diesem lied sehr
schön
[Musik]
ich finde den
von diesem lied sehr schön gehst du oft
ins kino
gehst du oft ins kino
ja ich gehe oft ins kino
nein ich gehe selten ins kino
wirst du oft an konzerte gehst du oft an
konzerte
ja ich gehe oft dann konzerte
[Musik]
ja ich gehe auch dann konzerte nein ich
gehe selten an konzerte nein ich gehe
selten an konzerte ich war gestern am
konzert von emsi usa ich war gestern am
konzert von mce usa die sängerin hat
eine schöne stimme die sängerin hat eine
schöne stimme der schlagzeuger spielt
gut
der schlagzeuger spielt gut kommen wir
gehen ans konzert von die wölfe komm wir
gehen ans konzert vom die wölfe spielst
du ein instrument spielst du ein
instrument
ja ich spiele gitarre
[Musik]
nein ich spiele kein instrument nein ich
spiele kein instrument kannst du gut
singen kannst du gut singen ja ich kann
gut singen ja ich kann gut singen
nein ich kann nicht gut singen
die komödie ist lustig
die komödie ist lustig der liebesfilm
ist so romantisch
[Musik]
der liebesfilm ist so romantisch
beitragen muss sich immer weinen
[Musik]
bei dramen muss ich immer weinen
der krimi ist spannend der krimi ist
spannend nach dem horrorfilm kann ich
nicht einschlafen
nach dem horrorfilm kann ich nicht
einschlafen
horrorfilme machen mir angst
horrorfilme machen mir angst in
kriegsfilmen kommt mir zu viel gewalt
vor
in kriegsfilmen kommt mir zu viel gewalt
vor dokument
filme sind interessant dokumentarfilme
sind interessant ich sehe jeden tag die
nachrichten
ich sehe jeden tag die nachrichten
ich mag filme mit action
[Musik]
ich mag filme mit action der regisseur
macht gute filme
der regisseur macht gute filme
mein lieblingsschauspieler ist moritz
bleibtreu
schauspieler ist moritz bleibtreu der
film ist so kitschig der film ist so
kitschig diesen film habe ich noch nicht
gesehen diesen film habe ich noch nicht
gesehen
kombi gehen ins kino
komm wir gehen ins kino
ich lese lieber das buch als den film zu
sehen
[Musik]